Here's your chance to build a stairway to, well, not heaven, but at least to a
gold cup, a virtual gold cup. This exercise gets you familiar with how most of 3
JS's, geometric objects work. You'll be spending your time working inside the
create stairs function. We're going to use the cube geometry method to create 2
pieces for steps, a vertical piece and a horizontal plank. Cube geometry's not a
perfect name since a cube is defined as having all its dimensions be the same
size. Box geometry would have been better but no big deal. Here's the code for
defining the geometry for two steps. The way cube geometry works is that you
provide it a size in x, y and z. It then creates a set of triangles for you
forming a box with these dimensions. Once you have this geometric object, you
can use it as many times as you wish to create 3JS meshes, each of which
consists of geometry and a material. You can use the position parameter on the
mesh class to re-position the box, and in fact you'll need to do this for the
exercise. When you create a box, it is centered around the origin. For our
vertical part of the step, we want this piece to be resting on the ground. To do
so we take half of the height of the piece and move it this distance upward so
that the bottom is now at ground level. The horizontal piece making up the flat
part of this step is created with this code. In this case, we first push the
step up half its thickness so it rests on the plane, then push it up the rest of
the height up the vertical piece, so that it rests on top. The z position has
also changed. Pushing the plank so that one edge is at the origin and that pulls
back a bit so that it rests firmly on the vertical piece that's shown here. Got
all that? Once you run the program, you'll see the two step pieces with the
vertical piece resting on the ground plane. You'll also notice a cool program
feature. There's some controls available. The grids can help you get a sense of
distance along each axis. They have lines every 100 units. Each is labeled with
the axis that are in that grid plane. For example, since the y axis is up for
this scene, the x, z grid is on the ground plane. Your goal is to build a number
of steps, one on top of the other going forward that just reaches the gold cup.
Here's what things will look like when you're done. Don't build any more steps
than are necessary or we'll charge you for extra time and materials, plus you
won't pass the problem. I recommend that you first play around with the position
parameter and see its effect on the model. Setting the position to zero shows
what the block looks like centered at the origin. You should also consider using
a loop as its a lot easier in the long run than brute force. Being a smart
programmer can save you a lot of groundwork. Using programs to generate geometry
such as a number of stairs is called procedural modeling. Personally, I'm pretty
bad at using modelers so I like modeling this way. It's great that with a few
lines of code you can generate pretty complex models. Here's a procedural model
called sphere flake that made more than 25 years ago. Around the same time Pixar
created a short film called Red's Dream. Primarily using procedural modelling,
since there simply weren't great modelling tools easily available back then. See
the additional course materials to download the program for this model and
others, along with pointers to many of the related resources, but don't get
distracted right now. Go ahead and build the steps.